uh what kind of things do you do purely
for fun that others might consider a
waste of time
purely for fun
because meditation doesn't count because
most people say that's not a waste of
time is there something like pong
that's a deeply embarrassing thing you
would never admit
I don't think well I mean once or twice
a year I will play a round of golf which
many people would find embarrassing uh
they might even find my play
embarrassing but uh do you find it
embarrassing no I mean I I love golf
just takes way too much time so I can
only squander a certain amount of time
on it I I do love it it's a lot of fun
but you have no control over your actual
performance you're you're ever
discovering I I do I do have I have
control over my mediocre performance but
it's uh I don't have enough control as
to make it really good
but happily I don't I I'm in the perfect
spot because I don't invest enough time
in it to care how I play so I just have
fun when I play well I I hope there'll
be a day where you play around golf with
the former president Donald Trump and I
would uh I would bet on him if we played
golf I'm sure he's a better golfer